Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so a whole bunch
of Deadpool 2 new mutants X force X-Men stuff
to talk about.
We got the teaser for new mutants already
the Deadpool writers have explained what's
going on with cable and they're going to spinoff
X force.
There is going to be a Deadpool giveaway that
I'll start all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a Deadpool related
comment on this video be sure to click that
bell to enable alerts so you don't miss anything
I'll announce winners at the end of this,
so number four there are two X-Men movies
that are getting made the film in Vancouver
soon, in addition to Deadpool too later this
year.
One of them is a new mutants we actually know
a lot about this because it's actually like
a real thing we know about the characters,
we no Maisie Williams is supposed to be playing
wolfsbane it's not a huge surprise there was
even an animatic teaser in the style of the
Deadpool test footage that they've already
released, so this is been a thing for a while
but if you've never heard of the new mutants,
it's the name of the comic book the Deadpool
in cable both debuted in that way back in
the 80s Chris Claremont big X-Men writer wrote
this spinoff, comic for a bunch of teenage
characters.
So you have to imagine the main X-Men team
is like the adults Jean Gray Cyclops Wolverine.
Those are the adult characters doing the really
big stuff is a teenage team.
They went off into the new mutants comic book.
But then cable came along and it turned into
something else, which I'll explain because
that comes back around to Deadpool to the
very first new mutants roster was cannonball
karma barrage sunspot and wolfsbane those
you keeping track of the timeline X-Men apocalypse
took place in the 80s new mutants is supposed
to take place the decade after that in the
90s, which is also kind of a big deal because
Deadpool in cable both debuted in the mutants
comic book during the early 90s.
So here's the new mutants animatic teaser
that they released I'll explain what's going
on in this after you guys watch it.
So what you're seeing here is magic wolfsbane
in cannonball fighting the demon bear.
So demon bears one of the big villains from
their comic book implies the demon bears going
to be one of the villains of the movie if
not the only villain we don't really know
how many other characters are going to put
in the movie beside this initial roster with
the current rumor based on how fast things
are going is that the movie is gonna come
out early 2019.
It could come out during 2018, but number
three next big thing.
The supersecret X-Men movie that no one is
talking about called X-Men supernova.
This is the rumor dark Phoenix movie.
So recently people started to notice that
there was a fox movie titled X-Men supernova
scheduled to shoot in Vancouver around the
same time that new mutants was going to be
shooting box just really likes to shoot their
movies in Vancouver so people like what you
know nobody is talked about this.
What is supernova what does that mean.
So the current thought is is that that just
an Easter egg for the dark Phoenix saga is
all kinds of questions.
It could be a number of different things they've
said nothing beyond the fact that they're
doing a creative reboot of the X-Men franchise
at Fox.
Brian Singer is out but dark Phoenix is like
the next big arc that they been ramping up
for they teased it at the end of apocalypse.
So even though I didn't really think about
it this way.
They called X-Men apocalypse the final film
in the first-class trilogy meaning this new
supernova movie would be like something different
going forward.
It would look and feel just a little bit different,
even if some of the characters of the same.
So aside from the characters that you absolutely
have to include in a dark Phoenix saga like
the main X-Men.
They said that Michael Fassbender, James McAvoy
and Jennifer Lawrence are still negotiating
to come back.
So you actually have to have Prof. X in there
somewhere, but do not be surprised if magneto
in mystique take background rules.
I would be totally fine if they did that.
I don't feel like they Apsley need those characters,
but the actors are so big that I feel like
Fox is having a hard time figuring out whether
or not they want to include them because they
want people to go see the movie.
The just trying to figure that all out we
can start freaking out about dark Phoenix
once they start talking about it I would expect
by comic con this year they'll have some more
news about that.
But number two the X force movie which is
a little more real.
At this point than the dark Phoenix saga because
the Deadpool two riders have been talking
about how the Deadpool franchise is going
to give birth to X force, which makes sense
for number reasons X force was always a more
adult hardcore version of the X-Men comic
book, so given that the tone of Deadpool is
both like really funny really hard-core.
It just a lot easier for them to introduce
the idea of X force in that movie now could
be Deadpool three, just depending on how fast
their plans for X force end up happening,
but the other big reason why Deadpool is so
important for X force is because cable was
a founding member in cable is going to be
appearing in the Deadpool sequel so you can't
do X force without cable you can't do cable
until he shows up in the Deadpool sequel.
So one thing at a time.
The writer said that they're not can a stuffed
too many characters in the Deadpool sequel.
So don't worry they could always push their
plans off to the third Deadpool movie, which
is the you have to imagine like some of the
cooler X-Men characters slowly coming into
the Deadpool X force universe Alexei Locke
would be a really great candidate.
She was a big member of X force in the comics
she was a character in X-Men apocalypse who
is kind of cool, but really didn't do that
but she didn't have that much dialogue so
you can put her in X force movie.
She can be way more hard-core.
She is a total bad ass.
It'll be a lot of fun.
I would expect to hear more at their comic
con presentation just like the other X-Men
films Deadpool is like the big Marquis thing
now.
So any time they make big Deadpool announcements
expect to hear them include stuff about the
other X-Men films.
But here's where we get the cable stuff because
cable forming X force was this really complicated
thing that formed out of the new mutants title
is Backstory is kind of a nightmare of continuity
of the Deadpool riders has said that they
have a really interesting way of streamlining
that.
Just in the way they streamline Deadpool's
origin story.
So number one Deadpool to getting ready to
make a couple really big announcements right
now they have an Oscar campaign is going on
right now I'll play that funny trailer and
a second or Ryan Reynolds said that there
still looking for their cable because he so
important.
But there are rumors that they've already
found domino so the probably announced Domino
first then will hear about cable really, really
soon.
The cable stuff though.
So for those you that are read the comics.
Most of you that have read Deadpool know at
least a little bit about cable.
So they start out as enemies that eventually
become friends.
The two of them together form this really
perfect comedic duo cable is the most hard-core
man of action in Deadpool just does not give
a crap about anything he has is really good
hard on them but he just will not shut up
so they kick ass together but it's something
of like a buddy road trip comedy the origin
story mess cable himself is the son of Cyclops
in a gene great clone called Madeleine prior
the story of how they got together is totally
crazy.
But then eventually cable gets cloned his
clone grows up to be strife and is used by
apocalypse and Mr. sinister to lead this force
against humanity so cables big thing is that
he comes back into the past to train a team
of new mutants in the new mutants comic book
that become X force to fight his clone in
the future, so already.
That sounds like a bit of a nightmare of continuity
the X-Men films already have enough problems
when it comes to continuity.
So the probably do is still make him the son
of Cyclops Madeleine prior travel back into
the past but run into Deadpool while he's
trying to do something else.
They butt heads until they find out that they're
trying to do the same thing, and help each
other out.
So if you've read the comics you know all
about cables Backstory the pry be a lot of
jokes and Easter eggs for strife Mr. sinister
apocalypse, but don't expect them to get super
complicated with it they confirm the colossus
mega sonic teenage which and Joe Pindar are
coming back.
So the pry the other characters from the first
Deadpool movie that will come back like blind
out.
They haven't officially confirmed.
Everyone is going to be at and you may have
heard about the funny trailer Ryan Reynolds
just posted is basically an Oscars for your
consideration trailer meeting were probably
not can win an Oscar.
But hey, we did some really cool stuff, so
please vote for us 600,000 Jenny Chung warfare
so fastest chaps. 12 humiliating minutes of
the casting capture 100 seventeenths for 406
Atlanta to know that a magical unicorn three
could that's broken still holding to rejection
letters from Fox video and 700 and Deadpool,
it was a longshot that they would've won a
Golden Globe it's an even longer shot that
they would do anything at the Oscars like
Deadpool totally does not belong there, but
what they did was so amazing that they deserve
to be recognized.
So I love the way they're spinning this for
more PR for the Deadpool sequel, there's new
Legion new Logan movie wolverine stuff that
I want to do so I'll try to update people
with the video schedule as I post new videos
game of thrones is going to be next, but I'll
try get to all the other stuff as fast as
possible while you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for defenders behind the
scenes directly ramping up for that right
now and you can click here to learn all about
Deadpool.
Wolverine crossover happening in the future.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!